مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيد نفع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللي اثار الكثير من الجدل على مدار
الشهور الماضيه على مدار السنوات الماضيه
حتى الناس بتعتبره واحد من افضل لاعبي
العالم وناس بتعتبر انه يفتقد شوي للعقليه
وناس بتتفق مع وجهتين النظر انه هو افضل
او من افضل لاعبي العالم وبنفس الوقت هو
يفتقر للعقليه اللي بتخليه قادر يتعامل مع
استفزازات الخصوم وخصوصا بالدور الاسباني
ولكن بما انه حكينا عن نقطه انه هو من
الافضل في العالم فامبارح امام مانشستر
سيتي فينيسيوس اثبت فعلا ليش هو بيتصنف
هذا التصنيف فينيسيوس لما انتقل لريال
مدريد بعام 2018 كان في حديث كثير عن
موضوع انه ما بيعرف ينهي الهجمات وانه
لاعب غير فعال وكان في احاديث كمان
وفيديوهات تطلع عن انه بنزيما عم بيطالب
لاعبي ريال مدريد بانه ما يمرروا له الكره
لانه بيلعب مع الفريق الخصم بحجه انه
اناني وغير قادر على التعامل مع الكرات
امام مرمى الخصوم ولكن باخر موسمين الموسم
الماضي والموسم الحالي اكتشفنا نسخه
مختلفه تماما من فينيسيوس جونيور شفنا
فينيسيوس الفعال فينيسيوس اللي قادر انه
يقود الفريق بالاوقات الصعبه فينيسيوس
القائد الفني والتكتيكي بهجوم ريال مدريد
بكثير من المباريات
فينيسيوس اللي ما بيعرف بلش حكايته مع كره
القدم عام 2006 واخذوا والده لحتى يسجلوا
بنادي فلامنجو ولما راحوا على نادي
فلامنجو سجلوه كظهير ايسر وفي ذلك الوقت
كان عمره ست سنين يعني هو مواليد 2000 بعد
ذلك فينيسيوس حاول او جرب حظه بموضوع
الفوتسال او كره الصالات بين 2007 و2010
تقريبا ولكن ما حب هذا الموضوع رغم انه في
نادي كبير جدا موجود بالبرازيل حب اداؤه
وشاف انه عنده الموهبه وعنده القدرات وانه
يقدم شيء كبير ولكن رفض التعاقد معه بحجه
انه صغير بعده بالعمر وقال له تعال الموسم
الجاي ولكن فينيسيوس ما رجع الموسم الجاي
واختار انه يغادر ويروح على كره القدم
فينيسيوس جونيور بلش مع فلامنجو كلاعب كره
قدم وتجاوز الاختبارات عام 2010 وصار يلعب
مع الفريق ولعب اول مباراه رسميه له مع
الفريق الاول في عام 2017
في تلك المباراه فينيسيوس ما كان مطبق بعض
ال 17 سنه اصلا ولعب امام فريق اسمه
اتلتيكو مينيرو ودخل بالدقيقه 82 في تلك
المباراه بعد ذلك بعشره ايام ريال مدريد
حط عينه على فينيسيوس جونيور وراح وقع معه
اتفاق للانضمام للفريق لما يصير عمره 18
سنه لان القواعد او القوانين باوروبا
بتفرض على الانديه او بتمنع الانديه انه
تتعاقد مع اي لاعب تحت 18 سنه من اي قاره
او دوله اخرى
فينيسيوس يقال انه انتقل من فلامنجو على
ريال مدريد مقابل 46 مليون يورو وهي اغلى
صفقه للاعب تحت 18 سنه في تاريخ البرازيل
على الاطلاق وهو ثاني اغلى صفقه للاعب
ينتقل من البرازيل الى اوروبا بعد صفقه
نيمار الى برشلونه من سانتوس طبعا الصفقه
للكل بيعرفها فينيسيوس مع الوقت ومع
الايام في ريال مدريد وصل لمرحله خارقه
جدا فينيسيوس مش بس لاعب سرعه ومهاره لا
فينيسيوس لاعب رؤيا لاعب تمريرات بالوقت
المناسب لاعب فنيا صار عالي جدا لدرجه انه
مبارح امام السيتي شفناه سجل هدف خرافي
وهذا واحد من الاهداف النادره اللي بيستلم
الكره من خارج منطقه الجزاء وبيسددها بقوه
بالزاويه البعيده او بالزاويه التسعين
وبتكون الكره في المرمى ووين بنصف نهائي
دوري ابطال اوروبا امام مانشستر سيتي
للاعب بعمر 22 سنه هذه شخصيه كبيره جدا
وهذا لاعب يمتلك العقليه بعكس ما يقال عنه
ليش لانه فينيسيوس باسبانيا الامور اللي
بيتعرض لها اذا بتعرض لها اي لاعب اخر كان
ممكن تنتهي مسيرته استفزاز عنصريه ضرب من
قبل اللاعبين محاولات لاخراجه من المباراه
باي شكل من الاشكال لانه فعليا هم مش
قادرين عليه على ارضيه الملعب بالكره لذلك
بحاولوا يطلعوا لمعارك ونزاعات خارج كره
القدم للاعب بعمر 22 سنه يمكن اي شخص بهذا
الامر اذا بتطلع فيه تطليعها غلط بالشارع
ممكن تستفزه وممكن يروح يعمل معك مشكله
ولكن بالنسبه لامر مختلف فينيسيوس عم
يحاول يتعامل مع هاي الاستفزازات صح في
بعض المرات بيطلع عن طوره وبيخرج عن النص
وبيتصرف تصرفات يعني مش مقبوله ولكن في
امور او في حالات اخرى بيقدر يضبط فيها
اعصابه ويسيطر فيها على الوضع رغم كل
الاستفزازات والعنصريه اللي عم يتعرض لها
باسبانيا شفنا امبارح ووكر اللعب عليه
مباراه ممتازه جدا حاول انه يحد من خطورته
ونجح الى حد ما باستثناء الهدف ولكن بعض
المباراه كان في لقطه ممتازه جدا لو كان
عم يروح يعانق فينيسيوس وكان في بينهم
حديث جانبي ودي لدرجه انه الناس والصحف
صاروا يتداولوا هاي الصور ويقولوا شوفوا
الفرق ما بين خصوم فينيسيوس في دوري
الابطال وما بين خصوم فينيسيوس بالدوري
الاسباني لذلك انتم بتشوفوا فينيسيوس مش
بنفس القوه بالدوري اللي بنشوفها بدوري
الابطال على كل حال وبالنهايه فينيسيوس
جونيور اذا استمر بهاي القوه وبهذا
المستوى راح يكون افضل لاعب في العالم بلا
شك مع الوقت وراح يمكن ينافس مبابي ويكون
احسن من مبابي يوما ما ولو اني ما بحب
المقارنات ولكن فينيسيوس بهذا المستوى عم
يعمل امور مبابل لحد الان ما عملها واعتقد
اذا كمل راح يوصل لمستوى خرافي وسيكون غير
قابل للايقاف على الاطلاق
هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل